- Let's wind down the hour
with something super fun from
the pages of social media.
This is #WHAT I'M LIKING.
(upbeat music)
(applause)
It's been an hour of superheroes
and I wanna close out with one more.
A Dallas attorney making a
statement on female empowerment.
She opened an all pink
immigration law firm.
Nearly all the 22 employees are women
and yep, they often all wear pink.
She's a real life Elle Woods,
And we have Kathleen on
the line right now watching
on NBC 4 Dallas-Fort Worth at three.
What's up Kathleen?
(applause)
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Nice to meet you as well.
So this idea came
after experiencing just
tons of sexism, right?
- Absolutely.
So even as a paralegal or an
associate attorney myself,
I was constantly degraded
felt to, or made to feel
like I was lesser than
because of my femininity or
the way I expressed myself.
So starting my forum was
really a way for me to
kind of embrace my femininity
in a way that I wanted to
which is obviously
embracing the color pink.
- [Kelly] I love it.
And you were in fact
inspired by Elle Woods character, right?
In Legally Blonde?
- That is correct.
So Elle Woods came out when I was a kid
and I love the movie obviously
because the philosophy behind it,
which is really that you can be
smart or taken seriously
and you can be feminine.
You can be smart,
you don't have to be boxed
in a certain stereotype
to be taken seriously
or to practice law.
So I love Elle Woods.
I'm all about it.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that too.
I see your kiddo picture
in the background too.
Super cute!
Thank you so much, Kathleen.
I'm liking your post right now.
(applause)
- [Kathleen] Thank you.
- All right.
That's not all, our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of FriXion,
the Go-to Erasable Pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you
so they're gonna give you
a thousand dollars just
for being you.
(applause)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
Well, thank you so much
to all our guests today:
Dwayne Johnson, Pierce
Brosnan, Aldis Hodge,
Noah Centineo, Quintessa
Swindell, and Mika Elle.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.